uh uh you're angel investing
tell me how did you get into angel
investing and then
how often do you invest how much time
does it take for you and how do you
balance it against
running your own company yeah so i am
a very amateur angel investor um i got a
little bit better after reading your
book which is
as you can see it's in the background
right here um
and uh we i got into it it's probably
just serendipity i think
steezy was actually one of the first
deals that i did and it was brought
brought to me by
uh uh vince who you're you you know as
well who sits on the board
and yeah evans thompson and it was
when they were just you know a team of
four i think
and uh they were i think at 20
000 mrrs kind of very early and now
as you know they've they've skyrocketed
and i just was just really i think i
just got done building my previous
company
and i really loved their
passion i mean i think evan ceo
was a developer and another company and
then connor
uh this co-founder cmo uh was working at
a marketing agency and
but they were both passionate you know
hip-hop dancers and they were like in a
professional team that won awards and
stuff like that
and like just hearing them talk about
the business like there's nothing else
they would be doing with their life
besides building steezy like it's their
life's mission if nobody funded them
that's what they would do and i was
really moved by that and i you know i
was like well i don't have a lot of
money to invest but
how can i you know get involved i mean
this this energy is infectious and i
think that's how i got
into anger investing and i think that
philosophy of just
learning from so i'm learning a lot from
evans and connor even though we're in
different you know kind of like spaces
um
but it's just that cross-pollination of
ideas and
i tell them that you know hey i'm not
gonna i can't write a big check
but i can talk to you as a founder i'm
in the trenches with you
um in a lot of cases maybe only a few
months ahead of you
if any and you know you can be really
candid with me i'm not in it for
financial reasons necessarily i really
just want to learn i want to you know
help out
and so i think it's been i don't think
it's been a distraction in the sense
that i really do appreciate like
cross industry uh conversations
and it just doesn't it kind of broadens
my horizons a little bit kind of
learning about like logistics and
in the world of b2b in the world of um
you know in the case
of a recent startup that i invested in
um in a
property reels you know property uh real
estate and tech and all of that which is
actually
related to outer what we're doing right
because we follow the real estate market
um so i'm just really doing it i think
it's a superpower
to fuel my own thinking about how to
build my company
better um anyway so that's probably like
a
loss how do you keep it from becoming a
distraction i mean the fact is you're
writing small 10 25k checks i take it
yeah so i don't know there's not that
much skin in the game
there's no due diligence necessarily i'm
usually obviously i'm not leading
right so like i'm following another
investor yeah and uh
and i really just meet the team like i
get to see them and then usually the
decision is made within like a couple of
days and
and if they will take my check you know
that happens so it's not
i don't actively seek out deals right
it's just like if investors
come to me it's like hey jake what do
you think about this you know what do
you
you know meet the founders um i do that
and if i can participate i do it that
way so it's quite passive
do you ever wish that you got to invest
in
some of these amazing ipos in 2019 and
2020
how about investing early that's where
the magic happens of course and well
with our crowd accredited investors can
invest directly and
easily in startups early before they ipo
and before they get bought our crowd
investors have benefited from companies
ipo and like beyond meat
what an incredible ipo that was and some
of the companies
from our crowd have been acquired by
buyers like intel nike microsoft and
oracle their
in-depth due diligence includes meeting
with the management teams of these
companies
and comprehensive vetting of deals they
decide to invest in
accredited investors can participate in
single company deals
for as little as ten thousand dollars
each time or
one of our crowd's funds for as little
as fifty thousand dollars that's why you
want to be part of a community like our
crowd here's your call to action today
you can join our crowd's investment in
nano lock
security this is a company offering iot
cyber protection including
billions of low-end devices that other
technologies cannot
protect nanolock is the only device
level protection that has
both near zero power requirements and is
operating system agnostic so
you can get in early on nano lock and
other unique opportunities at our crowd
dot com
slash twist once again go ahead and open
a free account
at rcrowd.com twist o-u-r-c-r-o-w-d
dot com slash twist